[Musique]
A.K.
Où l'envoyez-vous ?
J'ai très chaud mais nous devons le faire
travail PR garantir le lit de
Les enfants auxquels nous devons tomber
au travail très très très
difficile Comment faites-vous pour que les relations publiques tiennent le coup, ah
prendre un bain tout le temps boire
[Musique]
eau
est en train de filmer S
l'artiste en a un là-bas, à l'arrière, il y en a un
Le
[Musique]
Accrochez-vous tout le temps à la lumière manquante
Sans eau, nous voilà, Dieu merci
l'eau mais on ne comprenait toujours pas pourquoi
peu de clim, la lumière va bientôt s'éteindre
tomber, certains endroits ont des lumières, d'autres non
alors seulement ici au moins de l'eau
Il y a un voyage, nous avons pris cette eau juste pour
boire
hein
tout le monde va acheter quelque chose à la boulangerie 2
gar tu pars à la fin de
l'économie du mois compte que áu Maisa plus
[Musique]
en bonne santé
Le